لكن هل من الممكن ان تغير روسيا من
استراتيجياتها للسيطره على بخموت خاصه وان
القتال في هذه المدينه متواصل منذ اشهر
ربما قد تضطر الى تغيير استراتيجياتها
راويه هذا هو الجواب خاصه وان القتال امتد
لاكثر من سته اشهر دون تحقيقه تقدم يذكر
مع دراسه الحرب الامريكي قال ان الجهود
العسكريه الروسيه حول مخمود تشير الى ان
موسكو فشلت في التعلم من الحملات المكلفه
السابقه التي ركزت على اهداف غير مهمه من
الناحيه الاستراتيجيه اضاف المعهد ان
معركه بخموط مميته لك الى الجانبين فمن
الجانب الروسي يمكن لهم استنزاف قواتهم
وربما السيطره على المدينه لكن على ارض
الواقعه لن يكون المقابل ذا جدول معهد
دراسه الحرب قال انه حتى اذا دخلت قوات
الروسيه محمود ايضا دخلت الى داخلها او
فرضت انسحابا اوكرانيا تكتيكايا من
المدينه الا انها لن تعوض عن التكاليف
المرتبطه با القتال الطحن القائم على
الاستنزاف روسيا الان تسيطر على العديد من
المناطق المحيطه بمخنوط الا ان الهجمات
الروسيه حول المدينه فضلا عن انها تستهلك
نسبه من القوه القتاليه الروسيه تسهل
استمرار الهجمات المضاده الاوكرانيه في
اماكن اخرى الخسائر الروسيه في اوكرانيا
بشكل عام منذ بدايه الحرب وصلت الى قرابه
88,000 قتيله بحسب هيئه الاركان العامه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في تقديرات
صدرت امس مجله نيوز ويك الامريكيه التقت
بخبراء عسكريين قال احدهم انه بعد اكثر من
تسعه اشهر من الحرب ستسعى روسيا لمواصله
العمليات وتحقيق اهدافها المعلنه المتمثله
في نزع سلاح اوكرانيا واشتياث نازيا منها
بحسب موسكو خبير اخر قال ان التحصينات
الحدوديه الروسيه بالقرب من منطقه خارجيه
وهي من المناطق التي تشن فيها اوكرانيا
هجوما مضاده تعكس ان روسيا يجب ان اتخذ
موقفا دفاعيا وليس هجوميا في الحرب لكن
على الرغم من كل التقارير الغربيه قالت
متحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
زخرفا الاسبوع الماضي ان روسيا ليس لديها
بديل سوى تحقيق اهدافها في اوكرانيا مجمل
الاوضاع على الارض في مخموت يرصده لنا
حذيفه عادل
قد تصبح معركه باخمت اعنف معركه في الحرب
باكملها حيث يستوي الرسل للسيطره عليها
منذ اشهر يعني معهد دراسات الحرب
الاوكراني يرى ان ضخمه فخ لروسيا حيث
استنزفت فيها قوه جيشها بشكل كبير وتكبدت
في سبيلها خسائر فادحه تفوق اي فائده
عملياتيه من الاستيلاء عليها اما بخصوص
الوضع العملياتي الراهن فقد قصف الروس
منطقه الفاسكي وفيلا دار كما اجرت القوات
الجويه الروسيه عمليات استطلاع جوي متفرقه
فوق الجزء القديم